i just wanted to ask you um how much
would you like to return to the world of
star wars and if you could if you did
what would you like to do in that world
again well as you all know um there's
going to be quite a lot of star wars
around for the rest of your lives
um
and we all know that episode 7's
canadian film
now is taking the day off
and holograms and all the rest of it
there aren't any of that
but you know they're going to take many
twists from the story as the years go on
the world's been offered
and i dare say they may go back to a
time i've got no clues i'm just picking
off the top of my hair
uh when the emperor around the universe
and i don't want anyone else to play him
do i so
it might happen but
i'm not being caught i've got no more
the answer is yes you'd be up for it
of course
you